[Music]
bitcoin the best-known cryptocurrency is
reeling from a two-month free fall last
week the value of each coin dropped to
33 000 down more than 50 percent
from its november peak but many still
see crypto as the future of money
according to bloomberg the byte
administration is writing a first of its
kind executive order to regulate the
burgeoning crypto currency markets while
bitcoin may be a part of our future many
of us don't fully understand it brook
silva braga went mining
for a little clarity
ftx is the safest and easiest way to buy
and sell crypto it's the best way to get
in the game at some point not long ago
crypto trading went mainstream the
digital rebellion is here old money's
out it was probably during a commercial
break fortune favors the break
act now get in soon the ads suggest but
there's a strange truth about this hot
new thing bitcoin the king of digital
currencies everyone is buzzing about
bitcoin has already existed for 13 years
what is a bitcoin let's put it up on the
screen yet it can still be hard to pin
down what exactly it is or what role it
might actually play so this is the place
we found this we believe they're going
to take bitcoin it took weeks of hunting
to find a physical place we could use
the digital currency
plain slice we landed at helen's pizza
in jersey city new jersey i'm curious
how long this is going to take yeah it's
been a while i got my i got my app okay
jacob goldstein a financial reporter
with a bitcoin wallet loaded on his
phone selected wallet big point offered
to buy our slices okay you ready this is
go time
uh oh wait this is what we don't want
receive here
it's little arrow
send now okay
oh now the two-step verification step
very varication okay gotta open the
authenticator
the future baby the future of money has
a lot of steps
one reason bitcoin is cumbersome to use
is because it's a blockchain the public
place where every transaction is
recorded can't handle that many entries
at a time but the idea of the blockchain
using independent computers to
separately record and verify
transactions successfully did you get it
okay we bought pizza is also what
potentially up ends the way banking has
worked for as long as there have been
banks always before you needed some
central authority the government a bank
an insurance company to kind of keep
track of everything right and the big
insight of the blockchain which is not
limited to bitcoin is you don't need
that central institution a bunch of
people can all just sort of get together
and use technology to do it themselves
if everyone keeps the list no one needs
the list it's everyone keeps the list
the bitcoin code is out there for
everybody to see there is no company
called bitcoin it's just this code the
code went live in january 2009 satoshi
nakamoto whoever that is we still don't
know created a revolutionary scheme
bitcoin would be earned by helping
maintain the record of bitcoin
transactions it's called mining it's
mining right now oh it's mining right
now it's already mining
has been doing it for years
every bitcoin that people buy was mined
at one point or another it also what
makes it decentralized this is what it's
running on thousands of
systems like this exactly and then go
try to shut that down abada describes
bitcoin mining as a competition to guess
a password we think they're going to get
upset when they hear this thing a
password that gets harder as more
powerful machines try to crack it
oh now it's guessing a lot of numbers
yeah
so imagine having this in your house
i might get kicked out
it's become a computing arms race with
environmental consequences bitcoin
mining now consumes more electricity
than some entire countries all these
processors competing for the 6.25
bitcoins that are currently minted about
every 10 minutes it used to be more it
started with 50. 50 bitcoin
for 10 minutes
now we're making money and that was easy
to mine that computer could have mined
all of them back back in 2009 you know
the password was just much easier it was
much easier nobody knew about bitcoin it
wasn't worth much it was not worth
anything
until the pizza day
pizza day it's become a kind of holiday
raise your pizza
toast to the one and only laszlo it
remembers may 22nd 2010 when this man
oslo hanyetz offered 10 000 bitcoins to
anyone who would deliver him two pizzas
when the pies arrived the world was
different bitcoin a currency backed by
nothing but code had done the work of
real money like gold and paper before it
had value because a certain group of
people agreed it had value unlike money
you can't keep printing it there's only
21 million ever folks like idon are
understandably evangelical if they can
get more people to believe in bitcoin
its price will go up my boyfriend really
likes to tell me all about it you know i
block out after a little while but 11
years after pizza day bitcoin still
can't buy a pour over at seoul grind
coffee roasters or hardly anywhere else
it does let you store and send value
across the world without bank fees or
government meddling china found that so
threatening they recently banned bitcoin
el salvador found it so appealing
they've made it an official currency
financial services is a trillion dollar
industry one that leaves behind billions
of poor people around the world so the
dream is somehow not just bitcoin but
all the different cryptocurrencies all
doing slightly different work could
swoop in and take over there's lots of
things in the financial world that
aren't great for people where there's
unnecessary fees and too many middlemen
like try buying a house please crypto
please blockchain make it cheaper for
people to buy houses it's weird though
that it's been the promise for so long
now right like when somebody told me
about this 10 years ago i was like wow
that's really interesting and exciting
maybe it'll be money
and it hasn't happened yet actually it
might finally happen quite ironically as
big players take over the digital
dollars goldman sachs ramping up its
bitcoin trading operation that were
first nurtured by anti-establishment
cipher punks revolting against the banks
after the 2008 financial crisis to
senator sherrod brown that's more than a
coincidence i don't want to see a repeat
of what happened 15 20 years ago the
democratic chairman of the senate
banking committee sees the marriage of
crypto and wall street as possibly a
dangerous bubble in the image of the
housing collapse regardless of how
popular it is our job is to protect the
financial system from being infected
with risk that could bring everything
down the way this same kind of crowd if
not the exact same people brought the
economy down a decade and a half ago the
biden administration's newly planned
executive order will try to make
regulation happen by bringing together
many parts of government so far they've
all been stalled in part by uncertainty
over whose job it is it's appropriate
that they be regulated because of
uncertainty again
over what it is is bitcoin a currency a
security a commodity a ponzi scheme what
is it
it's
i guess it can be all four of those
so now there's a battle to control and
define this thing that has already made
some people lots of money i actually did
buy my test level with bitcoin i bought
a house with the bitcoin so you bought a
house with bitcoin yes but who profits
now and how senator brown says americans
probably shouldn't be allowed to trade
bitcoin anonymously more likely they'll
be pushed to use one of the deep pocket
crypto exchanges with the fancy tv
commercials i'm trading crypto when you
have like huge institutional players
huge sums of money invested what it
suggests to me is yes clearly regulators
might crack down
but it doesn't seem like they're going
to get rid of it all together so it
endures but i'm still not sure what we
do with it
me neither
and pizza may not be it i don't think
pizza is going to be it
for cbs saturday morning brook silva
braga jersey city new jersey
we have to appreciate the patience of
the guide helen's pizza 15 minutes to
bake the pizza then 10 minutes to accept
the but he bought his house with bitcoin
so in fairness and that will
communications it'll get easier as we go
along here great way to explain it we'll
be right back